p de la route voir là dedans mais s'y
joue
les instants le 19 mars si les nations
lorsque aujourd'hui à bagdad
c'est qu'au delà de la dimension comique
du film je les trouvais excellent et en
plus de ça à certains moments réellement
troublant et ça c'est fort parce qu'à un
moment on oublie que c'est un garçon
vraiment on vous regarde comme une fille
alors vous vous entraînez la non la
promo sur l'été pouvant table en ce
moment au dessalement je vais pas me
plaindre de ça mais je ne fais pas
partie des acteurs français de ma
génération qui discute on faut pas faire
de prouver ce nombre est quoi enfin bref
moi ça m'intéresse pas au contraire
gal elmaleh est un artiste de dimension
internationale de mad messieurs il a
commencé sa carrière au québec
pratiquement aux états unis on pourrait
dire à l'époque il y avait même pas 6 à
fait partisan d une heure d'avion mais
comme j'avais pourtant à l'époque cette
histoire et donc il a été élevé dans le
spectacle
il
tél
et voilà alors je vais vous faire un peu
une question de journaliste comme ça
tout à fait un tonneau et jeudis vous la
posez d'appréciation galerie en place un
gros boulot quand mam épilation rasage
la gaine pour le ventre plat les faux
seins la perruque les talons aiguilles
le maquillage dur d'être une femme gad
elmaleh oui en même temps je pense que
depuis ce crime là les fermes ont toute
mon admiration
il a toutes les réponses jeudi je pense
que la femme ne se résume pas non plus à
des apparats physique à des espèces de
petites modifications techniques je
crois que la femme est dans cette
sensibilité une prédisposition à les
mémoires mais je veux citer les filets
j'ai fait les bénévoles mais tous
complets non pas que pas complète papa
le pas le maillot pas le maillot juste
sous les maillots durable alors c'est
dur d'être une femme sauf quand c'est
vous qui fait l'homme voilà parce
qu'alors j'ai lu dans paris match
un article formidable quand on lit ce
papier on a envie de devenir excusez moi
votre maîtresse j'aime le couple qui
fait ensemble voyager ensemble faire
péter un costard aller au resto aller
acheter des pompes qui fait la lie
ce qui veut dire en français prise et la
vie
arrivé dans un palace se voir offrir une
suite mettre le peignoir ne pas caché sa
joie je vais vous dire une chose très
sincèrement avec la notoriété nous
arrive des trucs
moi ça me fait des fois sourire et
rigoler et je le kiffe
j'essaie de la jouer genre pas trop
impressionné devant les mecs mais c'est
génial quoi tu réservé une chambre
normale dans un hôtel on te dit monsieur
el maleh nous vous avons pris une suite
royale monsieur elmaleh la suite royale
si vous voulez bien me suivre mais moi
je suis super content je vais gérant le
peignoir les chaussons
je suis la france ouvre le rideau se dit
à ma meuf je suis pas foutu de ma gueule
non c'est vrai je dois dire d'ailleurs
que le gall pour une gonzesse c'est
quand même un bonheur ce qu'il aime
c'est lui faire des surprises
lajoux et romantique et puis alors très
possessif et ça les femmes adorent ça
qu'on soit possible s'il faisait qu'à sa
personne qui est possessive aujourd'hui
mois la petite séparation qui vous est
un couple ça me convient pas du tout
voilà donc en pique la balle de break
ouais c'est pas pour le break tu
maintenant je peux atteindre est loin
des yeux loin du coeur en même temps
ouais vraiment faut le savoir
alors vous avez beaucoup de succès avec
les jolies femmes 1
oui c'est vrai que
vous êtes un vrai bourreau des coeurs
non ça je ne sais pas enfin jeune âge là
on a des images ne rend pas bien compte
là des images
ah bon
gales oui être ou à cet instant précis
là maintenant tout de suite tout de
suite là franchement franchement
sérieusement sérieusement sans vous sans
vous offenser jamais en train de
regarder la télé tout le monde en parle
tranquille dans mon lien avec ma meuf
avec un bon un bon signe à la garde et
gad elmaleh à la télé ça vous plairait
non pas me regarder non non regarder un
documentaire animalier 7 gazil qui vit
au fond de la banda seul un cas ni en à
sa gamme
allez-y il y avait que des mâles n'ont
fait les femelles étaient tous large
pour arrêter ça me rappelle les tournées
vous auriez envie d'embrasser cru qui
vaudraient non non attendez c'est le
bras c'est une personne de sexe quel
qu'il soit oui alors là j'entends ram
embarquée dans un truc tu sais pas
comment tu vas t'en sortir eh bien il
faut m'aider il faut faire quelque chose
à gand
c'est que
jamais partie regarder gad elmaleh
pour enfants
gad et oui les meilleurs moments une fin
maintenant je vais voir si vous êtes
fidèles gad elmaleh
wasquehal